[Applaudissements]
donc avec fabienne puisque c'est pas la
première fois que vous venez sur notre
plateau et si vous revenez si souvent
c'est parce que vous êtes ce qu on dit
dans le jargon
et parce que vous êtes une bonne cliente
vous avez toujours le bon mot la bonne
réponse qui va bien bonne cliente
enfin chez nous du moins parce que quand
vous donner des interviews à la provence
c'est pas là même où la crise est encore
tôt mais journaliste peut-on avoir la
sensation d'être seul sur son plateau
alors qu'on est deux
la réponse est oui donc si vous étiez un
autre personnage de la série plus belle
la vie vous sur l'équipe
je sais je j'ai du mal avec cette
question si vous êtes une autre femme
flic notre femme flic notre femme flic
si vous étiez une des desperate
housewife à bas la brune
si vous êtes une autre chanteuse des
questions monsieur merci fabienne carat
[Applaudissements]